>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Sabrina Baron: Welcome
to the first meeting
of Washington Area
Group for Print Culture.
For 2017/2018 academic year,
we do six meetings a year.
We do September, October, November.
We do February, March, April.
And we have a very wide-open idea
about print culture, anywhere,
anytime is our mantra and we have
also done a lot digital humanities
technology presentations
in this group as well.
So, if anyone is local or
non-local for that matter,
that maybe interested in
talking to us anytime,
we are always happy
to hear about that.
We have been doing this more than
fifteen years, maybe knocking right
at twenty, which is kind
of frightening sometimes,
when we think about it.
But it's been a roaring
success and in all
that time we have never
had a bad day, never.
>> We don't mean to be putting
so much pressure on you.
>> And we know this is going to
go in the annals of that as well.
We continued this group, when
we started meeting as, you know,
everybody local, anywhere anytime,
because there were a lot of people
in the area, locally
who were interested
in creative cultural studies
and there was no forum,
there was no outlet here, locally.
That's what we aimed to serve,
and hopefully we have
done that a little bit.
We have a reflector email
list that if you're not
on the list you can talk
to myself or my colleague,
Donald Sutherland [phonetic
spelling] at some point
in today's proceedings we would
love to get you on the list.
We have a website; our
schedule is up there.
And we are going to be having
Tommy Lee, as one of our attenders,
as he speaks to us, Victoria Burke
who is going to be at the folder
from the university of Maryland,
who is really interesting
media transition stuff.
So, we have an exciting program.
So, we hope you, if you're
in the area, you can join us,
for as many of those as possible.
We go for drinks and dinner
afterward, it's a great place
to continue, continue the
conversation, meet folks
and I think we are a
pretty congenial group,
we have a good time doing
that and we invite you along,
if you're interested, in
coming along for that.
So we're going to be new, we
are webcasting, so we're going
to be working, what do you call it,
kind of dip the blocking on this,
so this is a new adventure for us
certainly and I think and to a lot
of us I think, to a certain extent.
We're very grateful to
the support we've had,
especially from John Holden who is
with the center for the book fair
at the Library of Congress
and now Mark [inaudible]
in the rare books division,
have been more than wonderful
to help us with this group.
So, Eleanor Shevlin is going to
give our speaker today Paul Salzman,
who is with us all the way
from Australia an introduction,
and we will move on to
the heart of the matter.
>> Eleanor Shevlin:
Thank you [inaudible],
will be giving a short introduction,
so we can hear and spend a lot
of time listening to Paul.
I would just say, that next
week October, not next week,
our next meeting is October 6 with
Michele Troy from the, working on,
who has worked on the Albion press
and her book will be coming out.
Today we are very pleased to
have Paul Salzman at the HA,
he's an emeritus professor,
of English Literature
from the La Trobe university
and he has recently been
appointed a Professorial fellow
at the university of
Newcastle in Australia.
So, he is from quite far away.
He has published widely,
on early modern literature
and his most recent book
is literature and politics
in the 1620s, Whispered
Council, 2014.
He's here on a Folger, short term
Shakespeare at programs 2 fellowship
and he is working, the project he's
going to be speaking about today,
his work he is doing there,
is related to his next book.
It's scraps, titled today's
talk is Scrapbook Shakespeare,
[inaudible] preparation
of a nineteenth century
Shakespeare edition.
Let's give Paul [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Paul Salzman: So
I was going to start
by giving you a quick guided
tour through the history
of Shakespeare editions before we
reach the mid-nineteenth century,
which is where we are going
to be for most of my talk,
and some people here are going to
be familiar with what I'm going
to start with outlining, so you can
nod off at this point and I'll let,
you know, when you can wake up,
which will be when we reach James
Orchard Holywell in the mid 1650's.
So, start with about how were
Shakespeare's plays were initially
published individually, in
a form known as a quarto,
approximately the same
size as a modern paperback
and was seen as similarly ephemeral.
Some of the plays were
published more than once,
in the quarto format,
Hamlet which appeared
in two quite different quarto
versions in 1603 and 1604.
The very first publications,
the very first Shakespeare
publications were in 1594,
when what we now call
Henry VI part two
and Titus Andronicus were published.
It was only seven years
after Shakespeare's death
that his plays were
gathered together,
and you might say were
edited for the first time.
The first folio published in
1623, large numbers of them,
sitting at the folio Shakespeare
library, just around the corner,
was put together by John Himmeys and
Henry con Dale, who were important
in the Shakespeare acting
company, the King's Men.
Contains few texts of the plays
previously published in quarto
and I see plays that were never
previously published, making a total
of thirty-six and establishing
Shakespeare's cannon.
Though that cannon did
end up in various ways
from the later 70s century
through to the present day,
when the attribution Phyllis
are currently having a field day
on who wrote what compared to,
Shakespeare and [inaudible].
for the rest of the
seventeenth century,
three further folios appeared,
and each one could be said
to be a revised, but
unauthorised Shakespeare's play.
So, the second, which was
published in 1632 was edited
to include minor updates of
spelling and punctuation.
The third, 1663 is significant,
because it was published just
after the restoration of the
monarchy, meant that the theatres,
which of course had been shut
for nearly 20 years had reopened
and Shakespeare's plays
were being performed again.
For the second impression
of this addition,
seven new plays were added.
All of them except the parts
of Pericles and that was seen
to be opraful and finally
in the seventeenth century the
full folio was published in 1694
and was essentially a
reprint of the third,
although it's a significant volume,
because it served as a source text
to many of the eighteenth
century editions of Shakespeare.
So, the publication of
the restoration folios,
coincides with the revival
but also the adaptation
of Shakespeare's plays, in
the new re-opened theatres.
For example, Dryden's adaptations
of the Tempest and Anthony
and Cleopatra and this
was the historical moment,
when Shakespeare was to
adapt Ben Johnson's tribute,
in his dedicatory poem, in the
folio, suddenly seen as not
for all time but rather of age.
Dramatists felt it was
necessary to drag Shakespeare
into the second half of
the seventeenth-century.
So this is when we had most famous
example, Mahem Tates adaptation
of King Lear 1681, and which
alongside many other alterations
by a happy ending.
Tates version of Lear had
dominated the stage for much
of the eighteenth century, although
it too was altered in various ways.
The editing of Shakespeare in the
eighteenth century was inspired
by similar ideas, which was that
Shakespeare was certainly a genius,
but he was an antiquated one, who
had to be approved by an editor,
in order to be comprehensible.
The eighteenth century was when
Shakespeare began to be edited
in a way that we might
recognize as modern editing.
His language and punctuation
were modernized,
editors annotated passages
that needed explaining
and they changed words and phrases,
that they considered to be mistakes,
whether the mistakes were
made by early printers
or possibly even by
Shakespeare himself.
Unfortunately, from the
very beginning editing seems
to have gone hand-in-hand with
mean minded bad-tempered rivalry
between editors, something
I'm afraid to say,
that continues to this very day.
Setting that aside,
in the eighteenth century there
were great editors of Shakespeare,
but they didn't really
produce great additions.
In 1709 with the publication
of the collected edition,
edited by Nichols Road and published
by Jacob Thompson, whose firm was
to maintain a tight hole on
Shakespeare during the century.
the structure of collected
Shakespeare additions was set
in a format that perseveres
to the present day.
This six-volume edition begins
with a biography of Shakespeare,
with Road excusing this with
the formula that was also
to become common during
the period, He says.
Though the works of Mr. Shakespeare
may seem to many not to want
to comment, yet, I fancy some
little account of the man himself,
may not be thought improper,
to go along with them.
His hesitation of the biographical
details and the necessity
of them was to shift
quite dramatically.
So that by the nineteenth century
every possible biographical tidbit,
related to Shakespeare was
treated with reference.
Including many that were
of doubtful veracity.
Road, also established a practice
of regularization of things like act
and scene divisions, as well
as standardized cast lists
at the beginning of the play,
along with the modernization
of spelling and punctuation.
Road based his texts
on the forth folio
and again he set a
precedent whereby most
of the succeeding eighteenth-century
traditions,
simply build on their
immediate predeceases.
Alexander Pope's addition
followed in 1725,
an in addition the quickly
attracted controversy
because Pope went much
further than Road,
in correcting Shakespeare's text,
in a move that we might say benignly
as one major poet reproducing
another,
in line with the literary
taste that prevailed,
a century after Shakespeare.
Apart from Pope, the most famous
writer who edited Shakespeare
in the eighteenth century
was of course Samuel Johnson.
Johnson 1765 edition became
famous for his commentary
and his much-quoted preface,
rather than his textual authority.
Preface, contains Johnson's
axiomatic reflections
on Shakespeare's universality
including the much-quoted phrase,
"Nothing can please
me and please long
but just representations
of general nature."
Johnson exemplified the idea
that I have been suggesting,
is reflected in 18 century
editing, practices in general.
That is that Shakespeare
needs to be extracted
from his historical context and
helped by editors to be confirmed
as universal, as not of
an age but for all time.
Johnson's addition was revised
by Stevens and then by Read.
And Johnson exemplifies
another significant aspect
of Shakespeare editing, that
again has had an influence
down to the present day,
and that's the practice
of incorporating earlier
editors, annotations
and often their emendations
in to successive editions.
The idea that each addition
built upon its predecessor,
was really only counted
by an addition
of Edward Tycho was
published in 1760's.
It was Tycho who pioneered the
idea of returning to the source.
So that he actually
collated the original quartos
and folios producing
thoughtful emendations
that are still referenced by
current Shakespeare editors.
Unfortunately for Tycho, his
achievements were overshadowed
by the work of Edmond Malone,
the first editor to be considered
at least by modern scholars,
as someone who approached the
methodological rigour required
from more reliable and somewhat less
subjective approach to the plays.
Malone tried to determine
a chronology for the plays,
which had in previous
editions been gathered together
under the generic categories,
that had been gathered
together in the first folio.
With the Tempest coming first,
and Sibling coming last.
Malone's edition was a benchmark for
authenticity, given his careful use
of early texts especially
his use of the first folio.
The influence of Malone's work
was consolidated, after his death
by an expansion and
revision of his addition
that was undertaken by
James Boswell Junior.
Published in 1821, this revised
version of Malone became known
as the very early edition,
because it incorporated So much
of the material from earlier
editions, reprinting the prefaces
from the editions of Pope,
Tible, Panda, Woverton, Johnson,
Caple and Stephens and using
many of their annotations.
This addition helps sway as
authoritative, until the middle
of the nineteenth century, when
in terms of editorial rigor,
it was superseded by the so-called
Cambridge edition, in the 1860's.
>> Paul Salzman: So, it's at
this point that I want to talk
about James Hallowell,
so you can wake
up if you were sleeping
until this point.
But I just need to say a few more
things about the state of editing
in the mid-nineteenth century.
The most significant and in the
end notorious event in the editing
of Shakespeare in the ninth century,
was the announcement in 1852
by the eminent scholar JP collier,
that he had come upon a second
folio filled with emendations
in early seventeenth century hand,
sorry it's not easy
to see that photo.
Collier's discovery caused a great
stir, which he capitalized on.
First that the book containing
a selection emendations,
which he considered to be by an
early owner of the folio whose name,
Thomas Perkins was inscribed
on the front of the volume,
and then in his 1857
edition of Shakespeare,
suddenly the subjective alterations,
and emendations of modern editors,
could be weighed against the bedrock
of someone, who is not only close
to Shakespeare in time, but Collier
implied perhaps possessed early
manuscripts, but gave
Pickens his alterations
to the text considerable authority.
And this authority of course was
transferred to Collier himself
until the whole situation
began to unravel,
as people became suspicious
the folio was finally examined
by various experts in the
British Museum and it became clear
that the Pickens annotations
were written in a modern hand,
pretending to be a
seventeenth-century hand.
this point in time
that James Hallowell,
had taken a cautious
approach to the denunciation
of Collier even though
he was certain
that the Pickens emendations was
spurious, began work on what was
to be the most ambitious and
expensive Shakespeare addition
of the nineteenth century.
There he is, in a very
handsome pair of trousers.
Hallowell was born in 1820,
when even as a schoolboy he began
collecting books and manuscripts.
Hallowell then went to Cambridge,
where he was at Trinity College
as an undergraduate and then
life, later at Jesus college.
He had a particular
interest in scientific
and mathematical manuscripts and
began publishing in that era,
when he was only 18 years old.
Unfortunately, his
love of this material
and perhaps [inaudible] the income
astray and he seems to of made off
with a number of Trinity
College manuscripts.
Which he made the mistake
of selling to a bookseller
who then on-sold them
to the British Museum.
That was, I want to stress because
I've become very fond of him,
which you do when you work
on someone for a long time,
his only lapse, unlike Collier,
who didn't do any thieving,
but he did do a large amount
foraging in his career.
Hallowell moved from
Cambridge to London and set
about establishing his
credentials as a man of letters,
becoming foundation
member of the Percy society
and the Shakespeare Society,
and editing numerous obscure
works for both institutions.
Hallowell combined his scholarly
and his commercial pursuits,
moving between collecting rare
books and manuscripts, editing them,
issuing bibliographical descriptions
of them and then selling them.
While he was still a student,
Hallowell had some dealings
with Sir Thomas Phillips, who
was perhaps the greatest book
and manuscript collector
of the nineteenth century.
Phillips spent a small fortune
collecting an enormous range
of literature and when he
was approached by Hallowell,
he allowed Hallowell to visit
his house at Middle Hill
in Worcestershire,
to help classify some
of the material that was held there.
When he was there Hallowell
and Phillips's eldest daughter
Henrietta fell in love.
Henrietta was a great catch
because not only did she stand
to inherit Phillips' estate, but
she has been trained by her father
to be a skilled copyist
of early manuscripts.
She was her letters and
diaries reveal clever was she,
and forthright.
Unfortunately for James and
Henrietta, Thomas Phillips who was
at the best of times and irascible
and greedy man I am to pray
with Hallowell's father and,
so he forbids the match.
The young lovers decided to elope
and Henrietta's father's response
was to disown his daughter
and then he spent the rest of his
life trying to ruin James's career.
There's a wonderful letter from
Henrietta to James explaining
that she is prepared to abandon
her home and her family in order
to marry him, but she
needs to know first of all,
what kind of financial settlement
he would make, if he predeceased her
as she believed that she would
never be reconciled with her father,
which was indeed the case.
James evidently set aside
Henrietta's prenuptial [inaudible]
and they were married
in August 1842.
Henrietta's furious father waged by
psychological war on his daughter,
who was his air, and
he spent a great deal
of time running his estate down,
in order to reduce what she would
inherit and most especially,
he wanted to prevent his son-in-law
from ever accessing his collection
of books and manuscripts.
Which he managed through the
contrivance of packing them up
and shifting them from the house,
despite all of Thomas Phillips
efforts, the marriage between James
and Henrietta was a very happy
one and Henrietta continued
to be an enormous resource for
her husband's literary labors,
undertaking copious
amounts of transcription
as well as proofreading for him.
James carer nearly came to an end in
1845, when those suspicious dealings
with the Trinity college
manuscripts came to light,
and his prosecution
was of course urged on,
by the constantly antithetical
Thomas Phillips.
But in the end, James was
if not entirely exonerated,
left relatively unscathed because
the accusations couldn't be proven.
He therefore continued
his combination of dealing
in early modern books
and manuscripts
and his editorial work moving
towards his Shakespeare edition,
for which a prospectus appeared
in notes and queries, in 1852.
Hallowell planned for an
addition that would be
in many ways a monument to
Shakespeare, it would act as a kind
of illustrated Shakespeare
encyclopaedia.
So in the notes and queries,
on note which is hard to read,
I'm going to read it out.
It says, "the works of Shakespeare,
the greatest of all uninspired
authors, should surely be surrounded
in one edition at least, by
the reading of the student,
the pencil of the archaeological
drafts-man.
In one edition, let every source
of useful illustration be explored
and rendered accessible to the
student and future editor and even
if that is something redundant,
much will remain suggestive
familiar explanations
of obscurities and
more popular uses."
During on his entrepreneurial
side, James decided to ensure
that the addition would be rare
and concomitantly expensive.
It was to be open for
subscription and will be published
in an edition limits to 150 copies,
printed on the best possible paper,
in a format mimicking the
size of the first folio
and copiously illustrated
by Frederick Fay Holt
and also would be full of facsimiles
of manuscripts and documents,
using techniques that James
had perfected for some
of his earlier editing
work and there's a copy
in the wonderful State
Library of Victoria
in my hometown, of Melbourne.
The key to this massive editorial
project is Hallowell's obsession
with illustrative material.
From a textual point of view, the
addition is relatively conservative.
However, I was able to draw a large
personal collection of early texts
and was also given access
to many held by others.
Perhaps the most notable example
of this was the University
of Edinburgh's willingness
to loan him,
it's then apparently unique
copy of the second quarto
of Titus Andronicus, which resulted
in Halle bequeathing the university
library and extensive collection
of his early modern books.
In that respect the edition,
had the merit of Hallowell paying
attention to early source texts.
However, he did not do a great deal
of what we would now call serious
editing, relying mostly on the folio
as his authoritative source
text, and while stating a policy
of relatively cautious emendation,
Hallowell frequently
changes the text
without offering much explanation
for why he does what he does.
He did however make the
vitally important point
that the first folio
had an authority
that the second and
third folios lacked.
This was not necessarily
taken for granted at the time,
when many early editors, as
I pointed out earlier on,
had given the emendations
and alterations
of life it folios some authority.
This is also an indirect criticism
of Colliers is supposed
Perkins folio,
because as Hallowell
gently pointed out.
Even if one believes that the
emendations and annotations
in that book where authentic,
they would in a second folio,
not the first, which have to be seen
as having only limited authority.
In terms of explanatory matter,
it's important to distinguish
between Hallowell's
illustrations, which are an original
and fascinating attempt to
contextualize everything
for the radar and his
annotations which tends
like so many previous
editions, to reproduce
but with due acknowledgment, the
explanations of earlier editors.
Hallowell was only unusual
in favoring Edward Thypo whose
fascinating editorial labors
as I already mentioned, in
the light editing century,
had been largely eclipsed by those
of Edmund Hallowell
will was writing.
So while Harriet Hallowell's
edition is not a very norm edition,
it does often sought the
most obvious annotations
from past conditions.
Looking at some pages of the
addition is rather like looking
at a Shakespeare encyclopaedia.
I'll take a relatively
minor play, the Merry Wives
of Windsor as an example.
Hallowell offers facsimiles of
the two early Merry wives quartos.
The facsimile process
for the edition,
was carried out by the highly
skilled printer, Edmond Ashby,
who had collaborated with
Hallowell in the past,
especially in the production
of the facsimile series
of Shakespeare quartos.
This facsimile process
involved tracing the original
and then reproducing it through
lithography, as opposed of course,
to modern a graphical
processes of facsimile making,
which develop later in
the nineteenth century.
So, the existence of
numerous facsimiles like these
of the Merry Wives of Windsor
quartos, adds to the rarity,
expense, an overall attractiveness
of how the Hallowell's edition.
Hallowell also incorporated
numerous painstaking illustrations
by Frederick Fair Holtz.
Fair Holtz had the unique quality
of being both a skilled
engraver, and an antiquarian.
Fair Holtz woodcuts are often
produced through his own researchers
as much as by Hallowell's
directions.
So just to take a fairly
random example.
Fair Holtz, both illustrates and
explains the partisan referred
to in the opening scene of Hamlet
when Marcella's office
to strike the ghost.
Fair Holtz gives us a description
of the particular type of weapon,
he's managed to find an
example at Goodrich court
and he offers an illustration
to show us what one looked like.
When you look through the 16 volumes
of Hallowell's edition or even only
through one of them, you can
see what an achievement was,
the edition, in terms not just of
its monumentality but also in terms
of its scope and the sheer volume
of information it contains.
It's true that the two
main criticisms aimed
at Hallowell's edition when it came
out was that it was too expensive
and also that it was overwhelming
and that the illustrative material
over powered the actual plays.
Now that second criticism is
of course a perennial issue
for Shakespeare additions
right through to the present.
Hallowell did not intend his edition
to be what we might
call a reading edition,
it would would certainly knock you
out, if you try to read it in bed,
but rather, a reference addition.
So the modern equivalent has been
the Arden series, where the notes
in some people's opinion
overwhelm the text.
Mind you, an item page looks like
this, while Hallowell put his notes
that the end of each
acts, so his actual types
of text are clean and elegant.
Despite its size though, the edition
was not able to incorporate all
of how Hallowell's
monumental research.
Hallowell might be described
as a compulsive collector
of material related to early
modern literature in general
and Shakespeare in particular.
And this was manifested in
an extraordinary collection
of scrapbooks, which he
assembled as part of the task
of putting the edition together
and also as part of his researches
into early morning
literature in general.
He then decided to put these
together to form a kind
of supplementary archive
to the addition.
Creating these scrapbooks
become a fundamental part
of Hallowell's research procedure
and examples are now large
at the University of
Edinburgh Library,
where I was looking
at them a month ago.
The Shakespeare Birthplace
Trust Library
and of course the Folger
Shakespeare library,
which is why I'm here in Washington.
University material was presented
along with a considerable collection
of early morning books
and manuscripts.
As I said before in gratitude
for the line of the times
and drunkest quarto and I'm
also Hallowell presented Denver
with 300 volumes of his
correspondence, they may
or may not have been so excited
about that, because the gift,
Henrietta's diary and about 100
volumes of notes, scrapbooks,
indexes, and other material
that was essentially devoted
to Shakespeare himself
as opposed to clients.
This included notes on
how Hallowell's meticulous
and usually completely
fruitless troll through records
of many counties and of sources
such as court roles, chancery
and exchequer records, in search
of references to Shakespeare.
Motivation to all things
connected Shakespeare extended to
and entire volume,
devoted to material related
to a story almost completely
discredited by Hallowell's time
of Shakespeare going
on a drinking spree
and passing out under a crabtree.
Hallowell even acquired two
volumes of material produced
by the notorious light 18th century
forges Samuel and William Island.
Samuel was a desperate
and frustrated search
of full authentic Shakespearean
relics and his son William obliged
by forging copious correspondence
supposedly by Shakespeare,
and an entire play and even a
love letter from Shakespeare
to Anne Hathaway complete with
a lock of Shakespeare's hair.
A similar lock has long been part
of the Folger collection along
with five copies of the love
letter and it's been the subject
of very interesting essay,
by Jonathan Gil Harris.
It seems that no one has noticed
the companion lock and poem
in Edinburgh University Library.
Probably like pieces of the true
cross, I suspect, lots of shapes
where in the late eighteenth
century.
Hallowell decided to deposit
the scrapbooks associated
with the actual folio edition,
at the Shakespeare Birthplace
Trust library in Stratford.
This was fitting because
Hallowell was instrumental
in establishing the trust,
pushing for its acquisition
of the various properties
associated with Shakespeare,
so he kind of pioneered
the tourist industry
for which we may or
may not be grateful.
And also with the establishment
of a library as part of the trust.
And he donated many
rare and precious items
from his own collection to the
trust as it was being established
and throughout the rest of his life.
When I first heard about the
scrapbooks that were associated
with the folio edition, I expected
them to be rough and ready,
perhaps like the recipes pasted
into old exercise books,
that we have at home.
Not at all, Hallowell has a series
of beautifully bound volumes,
roughly quarto in size.
There are four main things
that Hallowell collected
in the scrapbooks, cross-references
to ideas or images in the plays,
taken from the sixteenth and
seventeenth century writing,
actual textual variants of words or
passages between different quarto
and folio texts of the plays,
visual illustrations of ideas
or objects referred to in the
plays taken from other books,
and a very small number
of illustrations drawn
or painted by Hallowell himself.
So, starting with the first
category, Hallowell would
for example go looking for examples
of an expression such as Hamlets,
his quotas make with a beard bodkin.
So, Hallowell found
one, in a 1635 copy
of George Haeckel's apology
first published in 1627.
The first thing to say about
this, is that is evidence
of Hallowell's enormously wide
reading, because Haeckel is far
from being a mainstream author.
But of course, the main thing that
leaps out for a modern scholar,
is the fact that Hallowell blithely
cut the bid out of Haeckel's text
that interested him and
pasted it into his scrapbook,
leaving behind a mutilated pamphlet.
Perhaps we won't get too
agitated about a chunk as it
out of an obscure pamphlet.
But what about chunks cut
out of the second folio
in fourth quarto of Hamlet?
Here are some examples
as Hallowell ruminates
on the scene of Hamlet's fifth.
Starting with the quarto, where
the dying grown found only
in the folios written in, and
then from the second folio
with a suggested emendation
of all grows,
for all crows again written in.
There are many examples
of the sliced up quarto
and folio texts in the scrapbooks.
I should say that the current staff
at the Shakespeare Birthplace Trust,
are rather conflicted
about this evidence
of devil may care scissor wielding.
On the one hand they are
horrified that anyone would cut
up a Shakespeare quarto on folio,
on the other hand they all write it
to Hallowell, who is
responsible for many
of the unmutilated
early Shakespeare texts.
In the ninth century in particular,
collectors were quite prepared
to my imperfect copies of the
early books with pages taken
from other copies as well as
with hand-drawn facsimile pages.
So, Hallowell in his role as book
dealer, rather than editor was happy
to engage in this process.
This occurred most relevantly
with his purchase and resale
of the first folio, that's
known as the George Smith folio.
He resold it at a loss, I should
say to Frederick Overry offering
to replace the pages
that had rust holes,
with pages that he would happily
take from what he described
as the six imperfect copies
that he had lying around.
Interestingly Hallowell said,
quote "it would be a pity to do so,
the defects being insignificant
and the operation,
one which would impair the
integrity of the volume."
But Overry did take up the
offer and Hallowell Julie cut
out the relevant pages
and slipped them in.
So, scrapbooking from Shakespeare
quarters and folios was not uncommon
and far from a hanging offence,
however startling it might be to us.
Taken together with the editing
process as practiced by Hallowell,
this is really a notion of
the archive as an assemblage,
that it is empowering for the
assembler, it takes source material
as raw material to be shaped in
the service of a set of ideas,
being tried out as part of
the recontextualizing process.
If Hallowell cut up pieces of
Shakespeare quartos and folios
as part of his book
dealing, it's less surprising
that he might also do so, as part of
the scrapbook process where the cut
out sections, related
to textual issues,
that he was mulling
over to his edition.
However, when assembled
within the scrapbooks as part
of the accumulation of material
related to the individual plays,
the textual extracts become part of
what I've been considering is a kind
of supplementary archive
for the edition.
This process also bears
some resemblance
to the early modern
practice of common placing.
In general terms this is being
seen as a process of gathering
and reordering of information,
usually by writing
into a commonplace book
extracts that might
or might not be gathered
together thematically,
under a variety of topics.
This is generally been seen
as a process of recording
and to some extent even
rewriting the source material.
Either through the sifting process,
undertaken by the individual
reader/writer
or through scribal copying.
Recent approaches have
stressed that the practice
of common placing was eclectic
and that individual readers
or writers compiled
material for a variety
of reasons using a
variety of methods.
Adam Smythe for example
sees what he describes
as commonplace book culture, as
eclectic and highly individual.
Examples of commonplace
books look rather different
to Hallowell's scrapbooks,
because commonplace books were
generally manuscript compilations
of extracts, that were written out.
Printed commonplace books, a genre
that in some ways he dissected
with miscellanies of verse,
in the seventeenth century
were similarly compilations,
that looked somewhat
like anthologies.
But scholars have also
started to explore the way
that at least some instances,
texts were cut up and reordered
in the sixteenth and
seventeenth centuries,
and these reconstituted texts
I think offer suggestive way
of reconsidering Hallowell's
procedures.
Juliet Fleming has been at the
forefront of a materialist approach,
which has uncovered
a whole range of what
in the past would be have
been seen as transgressive
and unusual instances of writing,
notably graffiti, tattoo,
s and collage.
Fleming argues that what is being
seen as abhorrent was in fact common
and that writing was enacted
in the material fashion,
that's also evident in the more
conventional context of print,
whereas now will recognize
every individual copy
of an early modern book was unique.
Fleming together with William
Sherman and Adam Smythe,
Adam is actually talking
at Johns Hopkins,
I think the week after next.
So well worth going and hearing him.
So that is it a special edition
of the Journal of medieval
and early modern studies, devoted
to the idea of renaissance collage,
which includes the
process of cutting up
and reconstructing
books and manuscripts.
In the introduction, Fleming
stresses that early modern readers,
as they read and read by
cutting printed books.
Individual essays in this special
issue examine various instances
of this process in detail
through a series of case studies
of what Fleming succinctly
calls the customizing of books.
Flemings positive re-envisaging all
of the cut Is especially pertinent
to Hallowell's practice
in the scrapbooks.
She says "while it requires the
obstruction of one composite word,
it creates a new work within which
details of the old are revivified
and given a new purpose."
In his provocative
revisionist account
of the textual practices is
a Little Gideon community,
Adam's mind focuses on
what he terms the dynamism
of the reconfigured
gospel harmonies.
The gospel harmonies were folio
books that contained cut up
and reordered printed
texts of the four Gospels.
Members of the Little
Gideon community under,
the direction of Nicholas Ferris,
through this process of cutting
and pasting, turn the printed
texts into a harmonized narrative,
that would reconcile the
differences between the gospels.
One of the most controversial
aspects of this activity
at the time, in seventeenth century
was the including of large numbers
of images, redeployed from a
variety of sources and arranged
in the harmonies with
increasing artfulness.
I'm sorry controversial because
it smacks of Catholicism.
Adam Smythe stresses the way
this process was characterized
by an energy manifested as much
in the cutting as in the pasting,
so to speak and that the
reordering was dynamic
and ideologically charged.
Smythe lays equal stress
on what is excised as well
as what is created
during this process.
An insight is especially
relevant I think,
Hallowell scrap, scrapbooking.
Smythe says these books are
awkwardly placed on the border
of destruction and creation
or to put it more precisely these
books derive their liveliness
in part from an entangling
of the two.
One might say that the
confident slicing of the Bible,
at Little Gideon is replicated in
Hallowell's insouciant use of what
by the nineteenth century and
certainly by us, were books seen
in almost the same light.
Shakespeare folios and quartos.
A description of Hallowell
at work towards the end
of his life captures some of
the paradoxes of this process.
This is a quote, "along
one side of the antechamber
if you study stretches what Mr.
Phillips has named his book bin.
Every afternoon his habit is
to look over a score of books,
cut out of each the fractions he can
use and throw the rest as refutes,
refuse into his mammoth
wastebasket."
Hallowell's process of
refocusing cut from his collection
of Ellie my books can
also be seen in relation
to the nineteenth century
idea of the scrapbook,
as a form of information ordering.
This activity is being studied in
relation to the scrapbook ordering
of information gathered
from newspapers,
in Ellen Grouper Givese Writing
With Scissors, great title.
Erectile writing notes that
scrapbooks are the direct ancestors
about digital information management
and nineteenth century readers
adapted to the proliferation
of print by cutting it up and
saving it, and reorganizing it,
putting their own stamp on it
and sometimes recirculating it.
This is a process which
Givey describes
as performing archivalness.
The net description of at least one
aspect of Hallowell's scrapbooking,
although his stretches
beyond cutting and pasting.
We're nowadays perhaps more used to
the repurposing of illustrations,
the responses to these also the
is between the happy adoption
of illustrations removed from
the books of flora and fauna
and repurpose as nice
prints for our walls,
and horror at the vandalism
practiced upon books
that were intended themselves to
be encyclopaedic repositories.
A good example from the Hallowell's
scrapbooks is the illustration he
found for the referencing in Othello
to the men whose heads do
grow beneath their shoulders.
In the scrapbook Hallowell
places a hand colored engraving,
which he describes as rare.
In the edition, the illustration
is taken from a 1609 on mask,
held at Stuttgart by
the Duke of Gutenberg.
Finally, Hallowell, he was quite a
decent amateur artist [inaudible] a
few sketches and watercolors
of his own.
This one had me puzzled,
until I recalled Prospero's
trip to Ferdinand.
Seawater shall drink by food
shall be the fresh muscles,
typical Hallowell that he should
seek out and illustrate this
with a giant freshwater muscle,
from Sir Henry Dryden's Lake.
Sir Henry was an eccentric
antiquarian who lived
at Cannon Ashby where
the lake still exists,
and I assume the muscles do too.
Having assembled the scrapbooks
and then produced a final volume
of the addition in 1865,
Hallowell devoted himself
to writing an ever-expanding
biography of Shakespeare,
having produced his first
biographical attempt,
as far back as the 1840s.
The scrapbooks and the folio
edition were a kind of monument
to Hallowell's obsessive
archiving, but the biography
in its final form was highly
regarded and used well
into the twentieth century.
Personally though, Hallowell's
was life went off the rails
when Henrietta had a bad fall from
a horse in 1872, which resulted
in some kind of acquired
brain injury.
As a result of which she
went into a nursing home
until her eventual death in 1879.
Hallowell went into
something like a depression.
He moved to place near Brighton
and build himself an eccentric set
of wooden buildings he
referred to as wigwongs.
He also proclaimed himself to
be over the whole enterprise
of scholarship, devising a
postcard he sent out to inquiries,
which eloquently expressed
his current state of mind.
He labels this nose thumbing, my
reply to those idiots who asked me
to resume my literary studies.
He did in time resume, but I
think this eloquent statement
of the cheeky on way that can over
take even the most devoted editors
and scholars, is where
I'm going to conclude.
[ Applause ]
I'm happy to answer any questions,
>> Eleanor Shevlin: That's
what I was going to say,
is it time for questions, do
we have any questions there.
>> Would you say anything about
his relationship with his printers,
because it seems like these
scrapbooks were the penultimate stay
he had there in the printer,
he might be able to integrate.
>> Paul Salzman: I don't think,
well sort of two sides of that,
he had a very good relationship
with his printers and in fact
when the final edition of
the folio version came out,
he had a kind banquet for the
men of the press, in London.
There's quite extensive
correspondence
about exactly how he wanted
the individual volumes to look.
But in terms of, could have put
more you know, could have put more
in a not need the scrapbooks
my sense of what is going
on with the scrapbooks it that
scrabbling is an essential part
of methoding of his doing research.
So, there're kind of
two sorts of scrapbooks
and because I wrote this before I
had a chance to look at the folio,
the Folger material that there's
kind of archiving scrapbooks
like the ones at the Birthplace
Trust that a part of the edition.
And there's what we would now,
you know, stick on our computers
and our phones, take photos as kind
of you know, working in progress
and I don't think, I don't think it
could even be an edition, kind of,
had it been sort of a sense of
what he's up to, that he got stuff
out in print, but he
never really wanted it all
to be incorporated
because it kept growing.
So, the folders actually
have a very light scrapbooks,
where he kept revising
his biography,
came out in about five
different editions.
The very, very last time days of
his life he's still sticking bits
into a scrapbook that
are about Shakespeare
and I don't think would ever
really had a place in the book.
So, I think that's
what's going on there.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: Yes Bill, we're
going to repeat the question too
because of this new procedure.
>> Bill: I'm aware of at least
two major Victorian bibliophiles,
who cut up books, one
was John Roscan,
and the other was Philip
Augustus Handmark.
They achieved some notoriety, with
the kinds of things that they did,
how did this contemporary respond
to what Hallowell was doing?
Did they know that
he was doing this?
>> Paul Salzman: So,
this is a question about,
so Bill first pointed out there
are two figures, I know Roscan,
I don't know your other
person, who was famous
for cutting bits out of books.
I see, did Roscan cut Illustrations
out rather than text, or?
>> Bill: Yes, and it tended
not to be Shakespeare,
more illustrations and manuscripts.
>> Paul Salzman: Yeah, yeah.
On the whole, nobody realized that
this was what Hallowell was doing,
except in so far as Hallowell I
had said was a book dealer as well
as an editor and bibliographer.
So, he certainly had
correspondence with people
about that very common practice, of
how, how perfect you want to book
to be, shall I slip a few pages
from something else into it.
Yeah, that quotation
about him throwing stuff
into his big waste bin, comes from
very late in his life and prior
to that I don't think anyone
was paying any attention
to what he was doing
with these books.
He had a very keen eye for
collecting early in his career,
not just for pilfering
but for actual collecting.
So also think, you know,
there's a sense in which dealers,
dealers see books differently
I think, one the one hand,
they may see them as, you know,
sacrosanct at a certain point,
but that the opposite
at another point.
So, I wonder whether there's
the dealer Hallowell Phillips,
as opposed to the you know,
collective bibliographer
Hallowell Phillips.
I think was, was not happy
to do the that the chopping
and shifting and chucking away even.
As you see often in rebound books
that have what we now might think
of as, rather wonderful pages from
you know eighteenth century pages
that that wraparound
earlier books, when they,
that kind of process I think,
is, is, is at work too.
>> [ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Paul Salzman: Oh yeah,
yeah, yes [inaudible].
More than fair, I think,
I want to put Hallowell
at a slightly different
category to that one,
but I also see the connection.
>> It's a very interesting
theme, in your talk,
of adding and subtracting.
And the ways in which the early
examples that you gave us,
subtract from Shakespeare
what was not to be permitted
as not sufficiently moral or
not sufficiently contemporary,
and the now what we would regard as
sort of the editorial in succience,
would just stick in what would
be relevant, now of course,
so that is what kind of
addition and subtraction
and then we have the other end
of the spectrum, sort of massive,
endless almost a concatenation
of foundation materials,
which is this some of which
go into this reference edition
with almost a sort of parallel text
running currently with the text
of Shakespeare, which you said
was rather conservatively edited,
but still edited.
Now perhaps I'm working too hard
to make this into a trajectory,
but it does strike me that there
is a very different perhaps periods
specific set of attitudes
that are at play here,
it would bring you these different
sorts of additions and subtractions,
I mean I understand that Hallowell
may be a class by himself,
but surely the archive
or foundational impulse would be
something that he would understand
as need or appreciated, could
you say a little more about that?
>> Paul Salzman: Yeah, I mean
what I think is quite fascinating
about him, is his historical context
is that he sort of is the end
of tradition of editing
and Cambridge text
which is the Cambridge text in the
1860s is in a way the beginning
of the new tradition of
editing and so far, as you know,
that's the text based upon
much more scientific collating,
not scientific, but much
more meticulous writing
than the previous editors
would have thought,
what was relevant or necessary.
So, I think he's, he's
like that Victorian notion
of indefatigable assemblage.
And he's seeing a kind of shift
going on to some degree around him,
that in terms of editing is working
in a slightly different direction,
but in terms of things like the
biography for example, that was it,
so he thought quite well,
thought of, but then if you think
of how a Shakespeare biography
works through the 20th century,
it also works kind of accumulatively
on this subject to you know people
like Greenway, who won't get into
to trouble for making too much up.
But prior to that,
we've got that you know
that notion of give me the facts.
So, got the facts, this is
it Chamber whose who did the,
so Sean Baum does, Sean Baum
does Shakespeare documentary,
like which is just
kind Hallowell Philips
in the sense that's found anything,
everything that's got anything to do
with Shakespeare and just
stuck them all in a book,
because you don't write
a conventional biography
of Shakespeare because there
isn't enough material to handle,
though that doesn't stop people.
So, I'm not sure if I'm
answering the question, good.
>> How do the places that hold
the books today, classify them?
Do they consider them to
be manuscripts or books?
>> Paul Salzman: Thats a
very, very good question.
They actually consider them
to be headaches I think, so,
so Edinburgh they're kind of a
miss, because things there's a,
they're classified as manuscripts
in Edinburgh, and it defining list
that was typed up in the 1960s
is no, is no help at all.
The Birthplace Trust, treats
them with as I said kind
of ambivalent reference and I think
there, they're possibly classified
as books rather than manuscripts.
Folger, they definitely classified
under the manuscript call
number [inaudible] . Okay good,
good and I noticed that
in fact at least in,
at least one that I was looking
at yesterday, I mean, it's quite,
I don't know why this
was done because almost
at random just one engraved
map, has been removed
and re-catalogued you know, as a
map and put somewhere as a map.
This is in of volumes full of
engraved maps, I can only see
that this was, you know, a
rarer and more wonderful maps.
>> There is a whole history,
right as a collection,
one of the things we are looking
at, is how these classified,
because they were predominantly
pictures became art,
those scrapbooks are not a
collection, they primarily words
that made it a collection.
Ones that were meant to
be turned into scrapbooks
that never were, are
called scrap-boxes.
>> Paul Salzman: Yes, yes
exactly the loose stuff.
>> And Howard Phillips often
he changed his mind about some
of the pictures, so our
concern being art scrapbooks,
rediscovered with different
pictures underneath,
because they pasted
stuff over, so this.
>> Paul Salzman: Yes, yes, I've
been doing very well, it's great.
The only thing we couldn't,
so someone was asking me I
think sorry not at this talk,
about kind of reuniting the cut
up pages, which I'm delighted
to say I will never have
anything to do with, but,
I was exercising I think three
quarters the folders of stuff today
and yesterday, So at one of
the folders, the very first
of the scrapbooks I opened,
had page carefully cut
out of Rowley's history of the
world, Folgers, got four copies,
but on the various imprints
of the history of the world
and Sean Baum who's the person who
wrote the history of biographies,
written about Shakespeare, Sean
Baum's got this intriguing foot note
that they expect to probably
the late 60s where he says
that the librarian folder told him,
that this page from Rowley's history
of the world, was cut out
of an otherwise perfect copy
of the history of the
world, that the folder has
without giving it a
call number or anything.
So, we've now gone through all
Folgers copies, of the history
and certainly can't find the one
that the page was cut out of,
so you know, even way you would
think that would be really simple
to match page to book,
everyone's scratching their heads,
sorry but my point is a fact that,
that's a kind of false quest,
to try to match things
in, in that way.
But that's not being
true to the purpose
of what Hallowell Phillips was
up to, and I think what he is
up to is actually really
interesting, both in relation
to kind of early modern and in
relation to nineteenth century
and in relation to
current ideas about editing
and material book history.
>> Just to follow up, and this is
just speculation, but as I think
to what I would have done myself,
in his situation, but today,
do you think he had access to
a scanner or a Xerox machine,
he would have been satisfied with
facsimile that he could paste in
or do you think, because I would
be satisfied with that facsimile.
>> Paul Salzman: He was really
interested in, so he was very good
on facsimile, so he actually
published the whole series
of quarto facsimiles
which was quite early on.
So, he was good, when I
say he was good at it,
the facsimile maker was good at it,
but Hallowell was quite keen on it,
he was mostly keen on it
for mercenary reasons.
Because you could sell those early
facsimile editions at a good price
and you could also if you were
very naughty use facsimile pages
to makeup deficient pages,
you know in general books.
I guess, I was taking my photos
today thinking, so what I'm doing is
like what Hallowell was doing,
I'm snapping away madly really,
I don't think if each
given human a smartphone,
I don't think he would've felt that
was satisfactory I think he wanted
to type which is why I'm very much
in accord with people like Julie
and Smythe about the
process of cutting is,
is different to the processes
reproducing, so yeah.
>> I think my two-part
question comes together.
I think that you mentioned earlier,
that a quite different concept
in ones are also nearly all
folios and I saw you looking
at folios the other day
at Folger, and I wondering
that at any given time, Hallowell
Phillips had two or three scrapbooks
under process, he would put
that kind of thing here,
that kind of thing over there,
so that their kind of organized?
>> Paul Salzman: Oh yeah, they
are quite different kinds,
so the Edinburgh ones are
also nearly all Folios.
So, the folios are kind of
rough, so I would call them kind
of research scrapbooks and
the beautifully bound quarto's
at the Birthplace Trust, that
are arranged in order of plays.
So, if you call out Hamlet,
there are, you know, 12 volumes
and they're beautiful, like
they're really nicely bound,
they actually have stamped
titles on the bindings.
Whereas the big folio ones, are
much, much rougher, so I would say
that there are two
completely different categories
and sometimes things
migrate from one
to the other, but I agree with you.
I think that he's got them
piled high, as he does,
and his work is cumulative, it's
also say, instead of index cards
and instead of, you know,
whatever other process you've got,
through the years, there
are more and more of them
because every time you say something
that's relevant, he cuts it out
and sticks them in and
he classified them.
So, they are also, they're in will
categories, various categories,
in scrapbooks, which I would
say Folgers also got what were
in drawers in his study, which are
now boxes, all sort of ready to be,
ready to be pasted in,
but not, not there.
>> Oh I was thinking the
objects, example of something
that is mentioned in Shakespeare,
and he would go for an example
of that thing and those
are now in the boxes.
>> Paul Salzman: Yep,
they also had again,
but there's stuff that's also paper
things, not pasting into yet, so,
I think on his death bed, he's still
thinking what will I put in now.
>> So what was his method?
Did he choose a play and then look
for things related to that play,
or was it higgledy,
piggledy whatever he ran
across he matched in to folios?
>> Paul Salzman: I'm not absolutely
certain, so for the folio edition he
in volume by volume so to speak,
so I think there he was its Hamlet,
looking for everything
to do with, with Hamlet.
For the material, that's
everything to do with Shakespeare.
I think it kind of accumulates
as he goes, so he's a,
there's a really nice little
piece about him, by Bagby Somerset
who was the foundation
of regional, regional,
the records of early English
drama project and Hallowell,
is a kind of precursor to records of
early English drama, because he went
from county records office,
to county records office
and he would write down
whatever he found there
and that was this kind of, you
know, that was whereever he happened
to be, if he was in Colchester,
then let's have the record
office in Colchester.
So there, it was just kind of
everything that was anything.
I think for the editing
of the plays,
it was more methodical
play-by play, by-play.
>> Can you tell us anything
about how the various collections
of scrapbooks ended up
in these various places?
>> Paul Salzman: Oh
yeah, it's quite simple
because the Edinburgh stuff he,
he actually left in his will.
He also left Edinburgh a lot of
his actually early modern books
and then it was, he
was such a great guy.
He was very keen on,
the library at Plymouth,
and he left the Plymouth
library this massive collection
of early modern books,
and the Plymouth library
in its wisdom decided in the
1960s that it would sell them,
and Edinburgh University
stepped in, and bought them.
So, they kind of doubled
their Phillips collection.
The Birthplace Trust material,
he was instrumentally setting
up the Birthplace Trust library.
So, they got theirs as
part of that connection.
Unfortunately, a bit of
a sort of sticky end,
because there were all
these quarrels at Stratford,
over the running of the Birthplace
Trust and he ended up kind
of cold shouldering them,
but not before he had given
them quite a lot of material.
The Folger, bought theirs
and quite early on I think.
So, they came from, so they went up
for sale, probably in the late 1890s
and now I can't remember if the
Folger's bought them or whether,
anyway so the Folger acquired by
purchase, as opposed obviously
by the quest, because he
wasn't there when he died.
>> Bill: Did he have
a team of people,
the way Murray did
for the dictionary?
>> Paul Salzman: That's
a really good question.
His team basically
consisted of Henrietta,
who worked furiously for him.
She left this quite wonderful
diary, that is in fact in Edinburgh
and I know people talk about you
know, Victorian men of letters doing
so much, here's the Victorian
woman of letters, who gave birth
to a number of children and
helped raise them and managed
to do enormous amounts of
transcribing, proofreading,
compiling, but as far as I can
make out, he would sometimes do
that thing a lot of people
in the nineteenth century,
where he would write to
someone at the Bodleian
and say I want these four pages
of this book, could you trans,
could you write it out for me?
So, but, but not a team like the
dictionary team, no not at all.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: I'm just
going to say, because of a couple
of the comments too, that starting
the addition and subtraction,
other people collecting and
scrapbooking, but there are also,
and I know this isn't, I think the
whole project is very interesting,
this is not the focus, but I think
in some way this could to kind
of the technology of
writing and research.
I mean there's a lot that has
been done on this, but there seems
to be different formats, I'm
thinking of people scrapbooking not
in the 18th century for knowledge
production and collection,
that's also making me think, we are
going to end up in classifications
because that is that's more, and
some of the questions that came up,
because I think when we are writing
our meta-level, we are always taking
and subtracting from
different things,
to create our own kind
perspective and take of something
and the individuality of assembling
the pieces weather we are doing it
figuratively, where he was doing it
literally as well as bringing in.
So, it is interesting, to take
an even higher step back I think,
and look at this in a term
of a meta-look I think,
and then compare it to
perhaps other figures and look
at similarities according to periods
and then differences that emerge,
because of the tools and also
because of what the tools do
for many of us in terms of
what we think is capable,
what we're capable of, because the
tools I think also sometimes affect
the way we collect things.
>> Paul Salzman: Yeah,
I think that's true,
I not particularly taken back by all
the work recently that has been done
on renaissance common placing,
I think it's a really
interesting parallel to,
simply because that
what he's working on,
and the parallels seem me to be
crying out to what's actually made
and people have come up with
much more sophisticated notions
of what commonplace is, in the 16th
and 17th century, really you know,
wheels and notions of
yeah, kind of eclectic.
>> Paul Salzman: I do take
your point on the one hand,
but on the other hand sort of
returning to that notion of,
you know, Hallowell Phillips had,
had a smartphone or, you know,
what if the 17th-century
commonplaces had had a laptop.
I actually don't, I would want
to say, that it's not the same,
for all kinds of of reasons,
other than that it's
there are similarities,
but the processes and
isn't the same.
>> Bill: I'm sure that's right, but
at the same time, the similarities
as he took these notes in a
way we put these notes today,
and quite striking, I mean speaking
like myself, always carry my iPhone,
even in the library, there's a long
passage that I want to take note of,
I photograph it and put it
into a note taking program
and so I may type underneath that
or I may even draw on the computer,
it's quite a similar process.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: There's
also the interesting question,
is he consuming or is he producing?
>> Sabrina Baron: Right, because
they thought they were producing,
they call it printing
with scissors, they say,
and you know they think
they were improving it,
they're rearranging the text,
they were illustrating it,
the page is decorated with drawn
lines and so on and so forth.
So, they think they are
producing, but you know.
>> Bill: So, this is something else.
>> Sabrina Baron: for the
people and people got,
they even requested this
copies of what they did,
but they didn't look
great for example,
but that's another
interesting question,
is he consuming or reproducing?
>> Paul Salzman: I guess the book
dealings I would say the two are
inseparable, in a way.
That what he is putting out, depends
partly on what he is bringing in
and cutting up and I would suspect
the editing and that he would say
that the addition and the
biography couldn't be what they were
without this sort of
endless chopping up.
So, it's not, it's not
exactly the same but that
that would be the sort
of parallel process.
>> Eleanor Shevlin: And you could
preserving in a sense of collecting
and producing and you also, when you
are preserving there's destruction,
you know,
>> Paul Salzman: Yeah, exactly.
>> I think we have to time
for one more question?
no? Well thanks everyone,
and thanks Paul.
>> Paul Salzman: Thank
you for having me.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot com.